sans monsieur
oui c'est ça
attaque pourquoi l'appel au fesf à ml
oui oui comme ça tu crois ouais dis moi
tu as lu mon chalet sur canal là et
j'étais loin de me faire une petite
vidéo pour donner de la force est ce que
tu peux ouais ouais tu mademoiselle
partager sur les réseaux en fait tu m'as
demandé par message tu m'as envoyé un
vocal sur what's app est à envoyer du
courrier chez moi camille côté image des
reçus au caire at c quoi je raccroche te
fait la pub sur les réseaux pour ton
spectacle c'est bon bah merci beaucoup
passé comme j'ai demandé plusieurs fois
et quand tu es mon ami je me suis dit
c'est qu'elle échoue
elle fera étape à un crochet je pensais
de la sexualité
touche pas vous ne bougez pas tous
communient moneyweek sa gueule
me retrouver sur l'instant
et c'est ta gueule qui d'autre que
nostalgique là
conduit le maire de rueil malmaison
enfin des gens comme ça pendant excusez
moi pardon supporter légèrement